good morning it is um the third day good
morning of our trips yeah how do you
feel I feel great how did you sleep I
did I don't think I slept that well okay
why we went to bed too late yeah and I
ate late too late they the food took too
long to come yeah yeah but my Readiness
is not as bad as I what I thought so
it's good okay what are we doing today
we're exploring San Antonio we're going
to go to a coffee shop we're going to go
to the Alamo we're going to explore all
the fun areas of the city and uh take
you on a journey you look very tired do
I yeah look at your eye look at the side
of your eyes it's perfect good morning
let's
[Music]
go this is the coffee shop that Evan
wants to go look at the line up there
pretty busy very busy you want to line
up Evan what are you feeling you don't
really like line UPS yeah but it's okay
if it's really good then we have to line
up right I put a lot of pressure on it
being good if it's not good then we
blame on Evan wow cuz wow cuz he didn't
make a good choice wow if it's not good
rough that is
rough they are very busy so instead of
lining up we just to we just to take out
Nina hacks Nina hacks yeah so like
instead of waiting we we don't need to
sit down eat a big meal I just want some
snack so this is their famous Honey
coffee number one ordered thing on the
menu
good Nina got the cortado it's very tiny
it's like a
espresso Dr oh what oh zombie m fine oh
very strong strong yeah not sweet at all
no it's basically like a black with milk
okay you want to get dig into the bakery
okay we started with the chocolate
Nutella is Nutella or chocolate it said
chocolate but I don't know if there's
Nutella inside
okay nothing inside good I like the the
top that's very crunchy it looks like
the um the Asian the pineapple the Hong
Kong Le pineapple bun with the crust the
crunchy crust on the top okay we also
got the Almond uh croissant they say
it's a it's very popular it's what the
person in line and the person behind the
camera suggested
yeah y
me I don't there filling or anything got
the end but the sounds good next one we
got is a blueberry something it's like a
Danish but has a blueberry feeling
inside bear claw bear claw what is it
called bear claw it looks like a bear oh
it looks like a bear let's let's
see it has no it looks like a bear claw
it has like oh 1 two 3 four there some
cream cheese and blueberries
inside all
right good I like it job okay let me
try
they're all pretty light surprising I
would thought they'd be like I like yeah
yeah they're not heavy at all yeah it's
good yeah i' like to almond more good
job it's good yeah yeah good place okay
well you know what you you pick you pick
you pick good places oh well was it
worth it cuz you gave me this big um
what's it called uh if it doesn't work
out it's all Evans fall oh it's worth it
it's worth it yeah go yeah it's worth
worth it that's why there's so many
people lying up for good yeah good yeah
good okay what's what are we doing next
going to the Alamo what's Alamo um I I
don't know the whole history of it uh it
was showdown at the Alamo something at
the Alamo it's like one of the during
the Civil War it was one of the places
that uh did this big fight okay so okay
it's very famous okay in American
history okay how do you enjoy the sun on
your back I like the sun yeah I feel the
burning right now it is it is snowy cold
in Toronto Canada and this is outside in
the sun beautiful I forgot my hat oh you
want mine no oh cuz cuz it's not as
clean as
mine I'm joking I love you no it's okay
you need it cuz you you don't have
hair you're going to get burned if you
don't have this cover out of
here
[Music]
so there's another big lineup to go into
the Alamo
Alamo Evan huh why is everywhere we go
as the
lineup taking us to the best spot I
don't know if this is going to be worth
it but let's see only because it's going
to be very historical and think that you
don't really usually enjoy and like
super old but we'll
[Music]
see
[Applause]
n
hello
Evan how's the alamoo you like it I like
watching Nina like it she was she was
getting very into the history I like how
the country is built like the
colonization and everything yeah it's
interesting she was reading all the
stories and usually we we blast through
museums that nah was uh taking her time
like okay great let's go I like it we're
not going to rush
now you know about the Alamo uh kind of
not all but maybe I'll watch a movie how
it or read something about it but anyway
so what are we what are we going next
we're going to continue through historic
San Antonio I'll show you some of the
[Music]
scenery Evan can you tell us where we at
l
historic district Spanish historic
district here so we're going to go
explore explore what just to see what
they have
yeah
[Music]
atmosphere it feels very sketchy
Alleyway
Evan EV yeah can you tell me where we
going we're going to another area of
shops and markets and why you ask oh I
just feel I'm going through a lot of a
pain no suffering uh run down area
ghetto well between the areas is a
little bit of
ghetto but it's okay we're now close
okay look at these amazing shops H
where's the shop right
beautiful who are the shops yeah it's
all restaurant that have no one in
[Music]
there okay we're here at the farm table
one of the highest rated places for
healthy foods in San Antonio okay great
you sound a little
happier yeah cuz you're very hungry
right now I'm ready to eat a salad I
could eat a salad let's go farm
table Okay evan let's try your drinks
try house try
[Music]
something wow it's good it's got some
serious Ginger kicked is that a bee y be
that's some serious Ginger kick to it
holy
Nina's giving her what do you have tum
Kucha tumor
Kucha wow that's a shot time to eat some
healthy food yeah
wooo aa's going for the oysters
okay here she
goes she got six to eat I don't like
oysters yeah so I'm eating the
oysters there It Go
goes she's happy happy camper it's great
how was the food Evan pretty good pretty
light yeah I feel healthy you feel
healthy good and happy look at the laugh
that's what we that's what we really
paid for the
laugh okay where are we heading uh a
special place for Nina special place
yeah okay stay
tuned
[Music]
okay so the special place is HB not the
gasoline we're going to the store to
look at some um stuff that's why the
special store that Evan's talking about
Bina so we didn't get anything from the
store they don't have what I was looking
for you already have me here yeah it's
true you're trying to find a husband at
ATB no okay and then ev's taking me to
somewhere it's always construction I'm
always like doing skeptical where is he
Tak came in come on and then you end up
somewhere amazing what the heck you
hasn't learned yet how many years
together look look at all the
construction all behind
us where are we going though somewhere
somewhere
[Music]
okay where's this Evan this is uh the
historic district historic district of
what uh well San Antonio Market Plaza
okay and uh it's festive and fun and not
construction fil so wife is now happy
that we're
[Music]
here how do you like the the area here I
like the vibe yeah like the fun it's a
lot of Mexican stuff yeah this is the
whole point this is the historic area
all the Mexican culture stuff okay we're
going to get a lot more of that soon
when we go to Mexico Mexico yeah stay
tuned that vlog's coming what's next
something let's go see
something are we going to construction
site again
look
where's this Evan this is the main plaza
for what well it's called main plaza in
San Antonio and there's a lot of
activities and stuff that happen at
night I think they put movies on one of
these buildings okay doesn't look like
much is happening right now wait it's a
lot of
activities
yeah okay so what are we going to do
we're going to bring the
party
[Music]
h
you like the Cedro
Evan oh it's cool why is it cool uh I
it's just nice for for an American
church it's prettyy good yeah how come
there's a lot of gold St that's uh
that's the style it's a tradition oh
okay this is uh this is the courthouse
there this one is the courthouse yeah
okay if you get in trouble I'm going to
have to come pick you up here you get in
trouble no no you get in trouble I'm
always behave uh yeah yeah maybe so what
we
going somewhere
special Evan why you taking me to
another Alleyway look your arm what's
that look
it's a
bridge with a lot of logs yeah did you
bring logs no oh then why are we here he
because it reminds me of Paris when we
went on our very first trip and we did a
l oh I brought you to the love Bridge
cuz we're in
love so when Evan took me to the
alleyway which Alleyway we the last
Alleyway the one that we just went
through we we just we just went driving
all of a sudden we just went back to the
hotel and then we got that we picked out
our car but where are we going now Evan
we're going to your store natural we're
going to Natural Grocers just to see
what they have and then after that where
are we going Japanese Botanical no
Japanese tea whatever Tea Garden Tea
Garden to see I hope they have a lot of
tea because it's called Japanese tea
garden I don't think you're going to
have a lot of tea oh then why are we
going there cuz it's uh walking outside
garden
relaxing and it's Japanese you're
Japanese it makes sense I'm not Japanese
at all
[Music]
what
where are we Evan we're at the uh wow
why does it say Chinese Tea Garden this
is Chinese Tea Garden right there suppos
to be the Japanese tea garden you were
at the Tea Garden it's supposed to be a
Japanese tea garden but it says it say
Chinese Tea Garden chines Tea Garden
well all right great okay perfect we're
going to get a lot of tea let's
go
[Music]
a
I enjoyed the little Chinese Tea Garden
yeah it was different mhm yeah thank you
what the heck something just s to my eye
good what is happening no it's your
eyebrows my eyelash yeah no it's your
eyebrow on there you go better okay
what's next next we're going to go back
to hotel okay and then uh relax a little
bit and then we're going to meet Sarah
who is a gamer
uh entrepreneur friend of mine and we're
going to have dinner with her at
barbecue hello hello how was how was the
last hour in bed watching TV what were
we doing in bed we watched the
designated Survivor yeah it was a good
show yeah it was good it was good
Obviously good to lie down and we've
been walking so much today it's good to
lie down for an hour and now we're
heading to a Texas barbecue we haven't
had barbecue since we've been here yeah
so Texas barbecue place to meet our
friend Sarah and it's a 6 minute walk
and I'm ready to
eat Evan loves bringing me to a
restaurant that has a big line
up I try to get Nina the best I start
calling for reservation nobody pick up
the phone so they need to pick up the
[Music]
phone
is it good yeah moist very moist good
falling apart you picked this
place true I mean we just finished our
dinner dinner was just okay yeah they
out of uh the B the the beef ribs that
and the P Pork yeah you really want the
P pork no I really want the beef ribs oh
yeah beef fruit is better than pork I
don't know I like beef fruit better more
meat more meat more Mo okay anyways you
like the food can you just focus I'm
just trying to make sure I know where
I'm going um it was okay yeah we've had
better uh Kansas City was better Austin
was better but it's good you know Tex us
do some barbecue had some good
conversation okay let's go back to the
hotel yeah and chill cuz it's kind of
getting cold yes okay we're going to
walk back
and tomorrow we're going to be heading
off to Dallas where some amazing things
are going to happen and if you want to
watch our journey check the video right
the next to us you'll love it continue
to believe and we'll see you there